good morning everybody so I'm a few
minutes late before we get started can
thank you for that always a good way to
all right at this time I'm going to open
up the executive session on House Bill
54 FM relative to antique car
inspections chair recognizes
representative C for a motion
a move ought to pass on House Bill 54.
okay there's a motion about to pass do I
have a second
second by representative sellers do you
have another motion representative uh
yes I move Amendment
uh
2023-0272h
can you give me those numbers again
please thank you sir would you wish to
speak to your uh Amendment
uh yes this amendment uh keeps the one
part of the uh original Bill uh there
was some confusion about
uh allowing waivers of
of
um expections on cars so this keeps it
so that the inspection date will be in
May instead of April to help keep away
anybody else wish to speak on the
amendment
I'll mention one other thing on it too
um the change from April to May I've
been actually thinking about for a
couple of years for anybody with
antiques that sees a snowstorm in in
April it's a problem
um and in terms of the rest of what the
bill seeks to do we did retain our other
inspection Bill too so questions on
those things could get covered there as
well anybody else on the amendment
nothing okay
so at this time all those in favor of
adopting Amendment
zero two seven two H say I I opposed nay
okay so the amendment is adopted now
we're looking at a motion of ought to
pass as amended anybody else from the
committee
seeing none uh I'll have the clerk call
the roll and she's ready the motion is
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes the clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative Dumas yes yes
representative Melvin
yes representative foot yes
representative C yes representative
sellers yes representative Sykes
representative amanjapuri at Cecilia I
representative Fox
no
it's biennial representative Rambo
uh no
representative Ayo yes
representative Coker yes representative
Jones yes representative Rich Jeffrey
rich
yes representative staff no
and chairman Walsh
yes
17-3
okay our recommendation about to pass is
amended is adopted 17-3 it gets a little
bit too much for consent so regular
calendar it goes uh next up we'll be
taking up
um House Bill 55 at then I'm going to
close the executive session on House
Bill 54.
yeah I'll ask now any anybody of the
three want to do a Minority Report on
54.
okay
all right next up I'm going to open up
the executive session on House Bill 55
at then relative to driver education
chair recognizes representative sellers
for a motion thank you Mr chair I motion
to retain HB 55
motions to retain is there a second
seconded by representative Hill care to
speak to emotion
this this bill has to do with driver
education and looking at it
it's has the right idea allowing a
parent to teach a 16 year old up to 18
at 18 they can get a license on their
own anyway but at that point from 16 to
18 I I think we really determined to
take a better look at this and if we're
going to go this way to really make sure
we cross our T's and Dot the eyes
thank you sir anybody else from the
committee
seeing none
all right motion is to retain house bill
55. I'll ask the clerk to call the roll
when she's ready
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative
yes
yes representative Dumas yes
representative Melvin
yes representative foot yes
representative C
yes representative sellers yes
representative Sykes
yes representative Cecilia Rich yes
representative manjapuri yes
representative Fox
yes representative Rambo yes
representative yes representative Coker
yes representative Jones yes
representative Jeffrey rich
representative Staub yes and chairman
Walsh yes
20-0
1 all right a recommendation of retained
is it up to 20-0 no reports needed I'm
going to close the executive session on
House Bill 55 Atman
couple of minutes to reset we'll take up
all right I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill 93
authorizing municipalities to reduce
speed limits seasonally Jay recognizes
representative sellers for a motion
thank you Mr chair I'd like to represent
itl on hb93
representative sellers moves Ito is
there a second
Ed by representative seed you care to
speak to your motion
the point here is uh allowing
municipalities to lower the speed limit
for just a few months during a season is
is is is a good idea however it would
apply to every single Road within the
town and not just specific roads maybe
around a lake area or busier it could be
any Road in the town so that's why I'm
looking to itl
anybody else from the committee
well this is getting easier than I
thought I mean representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman
um I understand the why uh itl
motion was made but it's I was convinced
that dot had been making some progress
about uh authority issue that is
happening on many roads that are
um that have seasonal traffic issues and
while it might potentially open to every
single Road in the state I think not all
roads have seasonal concerns so and in
any event I'll be voting against the Ito
thank you anybody else
I'll just offer this I've seen this
concept several times now and I remember
hearing from the Department of
Transportation many years ago reminding
the committee that 20 miles an hour is
painfully slow
so you might think this is a good idea
to do this in certain areas for certain
times but for the majority of the time
people are going to get stuck going
painfully slow when there's no traffic
or whether pedestrians or bicyclists
present I know it's seasonal but this
does not limit it to to Vacation areas
this could be done by petition in just
about every Town Road in the in the
state potentially the patchwork that
this would could create I just think
would be unmanageable so for those
Reasons I'm encouraging everybody to
vote for the ideal thank you
anybody else
seeing an Alaska clerk to call the rule
the motion is Ito and host Bill 93.
Vice chairman Gorski yes representative
Smith yes clerk votes yes representative
Hill yes representative Dumas yes
representative Melvin yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sellers yes
representative Sykes
no representative Cecilia rich
Representative mangaputi no
representative Fox
no representative Rambo no
Representative no representative Coker
yes representative Jones no
representative Jeffrey rich
no
representative Staub no and chairman
it's a very good
11 to 9.
okay our recommendation of itl has
adopted 11 to 9. I'm going to close the
executive session on House Bill 93
um we'll be there will there be a
Minority Report you can let me know at
the end of the day on all of them
okay fair enough thank you uh next up
okay I'll open up the executive session
on House Bill 137 relative to boating
safety requirement rules and vessel
numbering rules and establishing a
committee to steady boat registration
fees
chair recognizes representative Gorski
for a motion thank you Mr chair I my
motion is to OTP on hb-137
representative Gorski motions ought to
pass is there a second
second by representative Dumas would you
care to speak to a motion I would thank
you very much
um basically this bill in testimony
seems like more of a housekeeping issue
where it clears up a conflict with the
federal law and because of that that's
thank you anybody else from the
committee
representative Sykes yeah I I agree with
uh representative Gorski this is a thing
that we should be doing there's some
important uh principles about when we
can get federal law and state law to
comport with each other that's a good
thing
anybody else
and I know we're all aware of how
reluctant we are sometimes creating new
study committees with the amount we
already have but good news on this bill
there are plenty of co-sponsors that are
going to be perfect candidates to be
sitting on this committee
um so with nobody else from the
committee I'll ask the clerk to call the
roll when she's ready the motion is
nope
representative Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes Mark votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
Dumas yes representative Melvin yes
representative foot yes representative C
yes representative sellers yes
representative Sykes
yes representative Cecilia Rich
representative mangaputi yes
representative Fox
yes representative Rambo yes
representative yes representative Coker
yes representative Jones yes
representative Jeffrey rich
yes representative Staub yes and
okay our recommendation of ought to pass
is adopted 20-0 any objection to consent
seeing unconsent that is I'll close the
executive session on House Bill 137 uh
give us a few minutes next up house bill
198.
all right we open up the executive
session on House Bill 198 FN modifying
the new Resident driver's license
transfer requirements Jay recognizes
representative Gorski for a motion thank
you Mr chair I my motion is to OTP HP
198.
um
octopass has been moved is there a
second
was that representative Hill
seconded by representative Hill
I know you don't want to speak to it
I'll just mention this uh we this bill
was actually introduced last year we did
I believe interim study it
um what it seeks to do is just verify
try to verify when people move out of
the state just to give some more
um
it's much knowledge about who is
actually here
come election time basically I guess
there's no other way to say it
um I know you'll look at it there
probably doesn't seem to be a whole lot
of enforcement in it but it does allow
the Department of Motor Vehicles to
reach out to these people based on the
information they have to verify uh their
current status so that alone is enough
for me to move it forward
um I guess that's all I'll say encourage
everybody to support the ought to pass
anybody else in the committee
representative shakes
yeah so I can't support an OTP motion on
this bill
um
I just think that it's a unworkable and
b that it's um
trying to attack perhaps a problem but
in the wrong way and the my mind the
bill is not ready for prime time and
needs to be worked on if anything but I
can't support it
fair enough anybody else from the
committee
representative Jones thank you um
how do we have a definition of residency
of established residency
some people might live here six months a
year
um sometimes it's your
declared domicile when it comes to
votings uh
in in this what is your declared
residency
so what would you do you have a
statement or did you want looking for an
answer to your question
it was more of a question you know it
was a statement and a question at the
same time okay fair enough
seeing none I'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll
uh the motion is ought to pass on House
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith
yes work votes yes representative Hill
yes representative Dumay Dumas yes
representative Melvin yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sellers yes
representative Sykes
no representative Cecilia rich
Representative mangaputi no
representative Fox
no representative Rambo no
Representative no representative Coker
no representative Jones no
representative uh Jeffrey rich
no representative stop no and chairman
Walsh yes
so the motion of ought to pass fails
I think
are there any of the motions
I have a question of the chair yep go
ahead so
um obviously the next motion
from my point of view would be uh itl
um do we need that in order for the bill
to go to the flow with without
recommendation or can I just go without
recommendation based on the OTP
fail
I'm quite certain we need the itl to
both to fail for it to go there with no
recommendation that being the case Mr
chairman I move itl
second
all right so what in expedient the
legislators been moved by representative
Sykes who seconded that representative
Jones
any other discussion on this
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll when she's ready the motion
right now is itl on House Bill
where am I
Vice chairman Gorski no
representative Smith no clerk votes no
representative Hill no representative
representative Melvin
no representative foot no representative
C no representative sellers no
representative Sykes
yes representative Cecilia rich
representative mangaputi yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative
yes representative Coker yes
representative Jones yes representative
Jeffrey rich
yes representative stubb yes and
chairman Walsh
okay so the motion of i.tl fails as well
uh any of the motions
see none I guess this will move on to
the host floor without recommendation
I'm going to close the executive session
on House Bill 198.
we'll open up the executive session on
House Bill 222
FNS who require the use of seat belts
during the operation of Motor Vehicles
chair recognizes representative Gorski
for a motion
thank you Mr chair
um I vote to on my motion is to itl
hb222
in expedient to legislate has been moved
by representative Gorski is there a
second
seconded by representative sellers do
you care to speak to emotion sir I do um
first of all I want to you know
acknowledge representative vayu for
bringing this bill up and I can
understand
um why he wants to do that
myself I do wear a seat belt and I
believe it's my choice and I do that
based on the information that I've heard
but it's a personal choice and for me I
look at this as a personal choice we
live in the Live Free or Die State and I
believe that you know each individual
should make that choice and we should
allow a make that choice and because of
that that's why I believe we should itl
hp222
anybody else from the committee
what a surprise representative
thank you Mr chairman um I understand
all the arguments
um around this bill and I don't take any
of them lightly
um you know statistically this
legislation makes sense that's why every
state in the country and 160 out of 180
countries around the world have the same
law or similar law
um it's it's about messaging it's about
what we're saying to people
when they come into the state or when
they drive in the state not having a law
puts us in company of such countries
around the world is Sri Lanka Bolivia
Afghanistan and Burkina Faso
um
so the countries that don't have these
laws
are countries that don't have a lot of
so
I take this very seriously because
statistics back up the efficacy of the
law it saves lives and we can find we
definitely have you know we're other
ways to
exercise our freedoms that
this doesn't take it away it's a
secondary law so it can't be pulled over
for not wearing a seat belt if you're if
you think you're a safe driver you can
still go ahead and
anybody else from the committee
so
this is a very difficult vote for me and
I I teach safety every day and
um I I know the safety issues with seat
belts I totally agree with everything
that you said and I don't let anybody in
my vehicle without a seat belt
um you know we I my law enforcement
people that come in and speak to my
classes always says to the kids you're
the captain of your ship so you're in
charge when you're driving and you
should make sure that everybody in your
vehicle wears a seatbelt that's your
right to do that
with all that said I've received phone
calls from my constituents in my
district
um who are against being told that they
have to wear a seat belt if they don't
want to wear a seat belt why should the
state or the laws say that they have to
and I have to respect that even though I
would never ever get into a vehicle
without a seat belt on it's really a
hard decision for me since I teach it
but I will go with my constituents this
time and vote itl on the bill I'm sorry
anybody else in the committee
representative Sykes thank you Mr
chairman
so
one of the things that always concerns
me about bills that uh have some
controversy to them is that we because
there is a little bit of controversy or
a lot of controversy depending on your
perspective we think we we tend to tune
out
real statistics that matter that shows
that in the case of this seat belt bill
that we should pass this bill because it
will truly and absolutely save lives
that is I don't think
I don't believe that's an arguable
statement on my part
that said sometimes it's also important
for we as representatives to
um
take a look at
what I'm going to call from for the lack
of a better term family history
and I'm going to do that right now is it
almost as a matter of personal privilege
but let me explain
I had a I had note that word I had a
younger brother
who
when he was 18 decided to hitchhike
across the country not exactly the
safest thing to do in the world but
there it was he was on his way he was
getting out of Dodge
and for whatever reason he got picked up
by this guy neither of them had their
the car was involved in a crash it
rolled over
the driver was was thrown out and killed
and my brother was stayed in the vehicle
but his back was broken and it affected
the rest of his life
and that that because
persons who were in the motor vehicle
who make that what they see strictly as
a personal choice choose not to wear a
seat belt are in fact potentially
impacting many many other people's lives
and for that reason and many others I I
have to support this bill it is the
right thing for the people of New
Hampshire even if
um perhaps there are some constituents
who feel otherwise I want us to be the
Live Free or Die State not to live free
and die state
anybody else from the committee
thank you Mr chair for recognizing me
it's a personal uh thing which I went
through with uh my husband being in an
accident in November
seat belt is saved his life and I'm not
a widow today so I see personally I've
experienced it it was a brand new car
and with all that he was hit from the
back at 50 miles an hour
and seat belt is what saved his life
and so
to me that's
statistics in the making
representative Smith
thank you Mr chair
so it's very tempting that we as
legislators Shuffle these pieces of
paper and they're gone and the governor
signs them and we think something
happens I don't have the list with me
but New Hampshire has a better rate of
seat belt use in some states that have
mandatory seat belt laws I don't know
if the bill will actually do anything
so there's that with the usage go up
would it go down my people rebel now
that they're being forced to wear it I
wouldn't want to endanger that the value
that we have
and there's anecdotal stories on both
sides
the uh this isn't my first rodeo with
this and I have recounted the story of
when we were hit by a drunk driver doing
100 miles an hour flipped up on our side
and I would not have been able to get my
son out of the back seat which was the
back of the car was pretty mangled the
window was gone the fenders were gone
the guy drove right into our trunk we
were sitting there hanging on our side
because I wasn't wearing one at that
moment I was able to get in the back and
get them out otherwise you would have
hung there for the 45 minutes that my
wife was trapped in the car
so anecdotes are very powerful and they
affect us emotionally
but they're not statistical
in in previous iterations of this bill
we've heard stories of people that would
have been killed had they been strapped
right in place as the steering wheel
came back through them so
it's tough to ignore the anecdotes but
it's important to remember that they're
on both sides and
we also don't know if the bill is
actually going to do anything at this
point so I'll support the itl
anybody else from the committee
yes I saw representative Jones first
thank you Mr chair
um
and sometimes they may sound like a
broken record when I say the same thing
for different bills but um 2022 deaths
by accident rates in New Hampshire were
way up
and it's not law enforcement who gets to
change that it's it's us here who who
create policies that can change it with
little steps like this
that we can do that to make it a safer
state so I will not be supporting itl
representative
I'd like to make a clarification we
received this information during the the
last hearing and it shows that New
Hampshire of all the United States has
the lowest rate of compliance with the
seat belts except for Virgin Islands so
that's the only other place that that
has lower seat belt compliance and they
do have a primary seat belt law
I don't have that in front of me but I
have no reason to dispute you
representative sellers
thank you Mr chair
so a couple things coming out to me on
this and and I
just automatically New Hampshire puts
their seat belts on from what I remember
from the hearings 75 of the time or a
little bit more versus the other states
around us are right around 90. so well
just 15 off think about that way and
that's voluntarily doing it
the other part that really comes to me
which is more important than anything is
one gentleman testified he says this is
going against my constitutional rights
and uh first part Article 2 and also the
first part article three he says this
was actually going against the
Constitution we all took an O to uphold
the Constitution
so therefore you have to itl this
otherwise you're going against the
Constitution and article 3.
seeing none I'll just add a couple of a
couple of thoughts I couldn't make the
public hearing I apologize but I did
watch it online and
I did hear Captain better say that in
his 31 years he's been here
promoting reducing crashes
and so do I have been on this committee
this is my 11th year now and I support
things even though a lot of people don't
like it to try to reduce crashes because
I firmly believe that's how we can see
some of our death rates go down there's
nothing about a mandatory seat belt that
is going to reduce crashes some of these
safety devices whether it's seat belts
or helmets they might make it a safer
crash they may not there's a lot of
other arguments of saying that sometimes
the seat belts as a distraction can
cause crashes so again this is just
I don't see any evidence that this is
going to help anything and just because
some of the other states have 90 percent
usage according to that study they're
not living in New Hampshire I don't know
and nobody can it's not proven whether
or not even if this was mandatory second
secondary or not that we would ever see
the 90. it's New Hampshire we are a
different store so for those reasons and
everything else I heard because it's
been a great great debate I will be
supporting the itl as well anybody else
from the committee
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role when she's ready the motion is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
222.
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes
clerk votes yes representative Hill yes
representative Dumas yes representative
Melvin yes representative foot yes
representative C yes representative
sellers yes representative Sykes
no representative Cecilia rich
representative manjapuri
no representative Fox
no representative Rambo no
Representative
no representative Coker yes
representative Jones no
representative uh Jeffrey rich
no representative Staub no
seven to nine
uh
I I expected so okay so our committee
recommendation of inexpedia to
legislators adopted 11 to nine I've just
informed it will be a Minority Report uh
I'll close the executive session on
House Bill 222.
uh next up give us a few moments
um
foreign
open up the executive session on House
Bill 370 FN relative to aftermarket
tinting on Motor Vehicles for drivers
with medical conditions chair recognizes
representative Crawford for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I make a motion to
retain has been moved is there a second
seconded by representative Coker care to
speak to motion
I I believe we want to take
um 370 and do a little bit of work on it
so that's why we're going to retain it
we hope that we'll retain it
fair enough I'll add that we've been
talking about tinted windows in
different areas of the vehicle for many
years now we've made a couple of
attempted changes it seems like when we
do we confuse another sentence
um so I was pretty much agreed at our
public hearing with not just the
committee but with the Department of
Motor Vehicles perhaps we should take
these bills retain them and legitimately
work on them over the summer so that we
don't keep convoluting the chapter let's
try to straighten out the whole thing
once and for all uh anybody else from
the committee
representative sellers thank you Mr
chair yeah one thing I was hearing
through the whole committee is we all
got confused we didn't know what
percentage of tinting was automatically
placed on the windows we didn't realize
there was tinting on the Windows already
so to retain it I think is put some
clarity to that
fair enough we'll go over how this whole
process works if this is successful the
retain at the end anybody else from the
committee representative Smith
yeah it's super frustrating that this
was going on back when I was sharing the
committee and the positions Committee of
the committee's position has always been
Crystal Clear once we got to it that we
would allow aftermarket tension at the
same level that you could get on a brand
new car because Nitza has deemed that
safe it's mind-boggling to me that we
haven't come up with a statute that
reflects that so yeah I agree it's a
good case for retain because I think
we're together on the position we'll
anybody else
Cena I'll ask the clerk to call the roll
you'll set
I'll ask the clerk to call the roll the
motion is retain on House Bill 370 FN
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
Dumas yes representative Melvin yes
representative foot yes representative C
yes representative sellers yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Cecilia rich
representative anjapuri
yes representative Fox yes
representative Rambo yes representative
yes representative Coker yes
representative Jones yes representative
Jeffrey Rich yes representative yes and
chairman Welsh yes 20-0
our committee recommendation to retain
370 is adopted I'll close the executive
session on House Bill 370 FN I am going
to go a little out of order
uh representative Crawford only to keep
the context well uh consistent 537 next
okay we're gonna open up the executive
session on House Bill 5 37 FN permitting
vehicles to have front windshield
tinting chair recognizes representative
Crawford for a motion thank you Mr
chairman I'm
I
um
I'm like like I moved her chain uh House
Bill 537 event second Mr chairman okay
routine's been moved and seconded by
and while she's getting caught up I'll
speak to it briefly uh this again is uh
dealing with windshield tinting
um and so for all the reasons we just
mentioned on the last bill is a good
reason to retain uh I will Echo those
the only reason we arguably don't need
both of these to retain to work on them
uh the reason I'm just keeping this is
to be cautious this one deals
specifically with ceramic coats that are
kind of A New Concept I don't know much
about them at this point either I just
don't want to risk losing the ability to
maybe introducing them if they work with
an itl so that's why I'm deciding to
hopefully retain both of them I hope you
can support that anybody else from the
committee
representative Johnson yes thank you Mr
chair uh the day we heard these there
was a lot of crossover between this one
and 370 and causing more confusion I
think we're doing the right thing by
retaining and getting it right
thank you for that anybody else from the
committee
CNN I'll ask the clerk to call the roll
motion on post Bill 537 is to retain
Vice chairman Gorski yes representative
Smith
yes clerk votes yes representative Hill
yes representative debase yes
representative Melvin yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sellers yes
representative Sykes
yes representative Cecilia Rich
representative mangaputi
yes representative Fox yes
representative Rambo yes representative
yes representative Coker
yes representative Jones yes
representative Jeffrey Rich yes
representative Staub yes and chairman
Walsh yes 20-0
okay so the retain is approved or
adopted 20-0 we'll close the executive
session on House Bill 537.
um I have a couple of I personally have
a couple of questions I didn't want to
ask a few people on 570
so what I'm going to do
I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill 570. and I'm going
to recess the executive session on House
11 15.
foreign
okay welcome back being one uh 11 17.
I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill 570 relative to
real ID compliant New Hampshire driver's
licenses chair recognizes representative
Coker for a motion
I make a motion to retain 570. retain
has been moved is there a second
seconded by representative Hill care to
speak to your motion uh yes Sharon I do
thank you
um so you know the real ID is a serious
ID it gives you access to Federal
facilities for travel
so on one side of the coin I don't want
to deprive people who are legally here
to you know I don't want to deprive them
of this ID but on the other hand I don't
want to issue it prematurely without the
proper Safeguard so in talking to the
DMV there were some issues different
phases people go through in the process
so I think retaining this bill allows us
to explore that a little bit further
thank you sir anybody else from the
committee
representative Sykes
so I think that the this is a reasonable
way for us to proceed
um I actually agree with everything that
representative coca had to say that
there's questions to be asked answers to
anybody else
I'll just add I'm not necessarily a fan
of this but I do understand that our
ranking member has been working hard and
thinks he's close uh there are good
points to it uh and nobody will ever
state it on Transportation we're not
fair I'll give them the opportunity to
continue to work on it with nothing else
I'll ask the clerk to call the role when
she's ready motion is retained on House
Bill 570.
Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes
representative Hill yes representative
domains yes representative Melvin yes
representative foot yes representative C
yes representative sellers yes
representative Sykes yes Representatives
uh Cecil
Cecilia Rich yes
representative
yes representative Fox yes
representative Rambo yes representative
yes representative Coker yes
representative Jones yes representative
Rich yes representative staff yes and
chairman Walsh yes
20-0
okay retain 20 to zero I'm going to
close the executive session on House
Bill 570.
that
is a wrap for our house bills for this
year I want to thank everybody uh we we
did pretty well
um for the rest of today just so I can
close the books on these if I can get
all my committee reports both majority
and minority we've got plenty of time
um be nice for me to be able to submit
them all before I leave
any questions from anybody on where
we're headed next go ahead uh have you
looked to see if there's any potential
bills in the Senate that might be coming
to us
I have not sat down with the chair of
Transportation in the Senate yet I plan
on scheduling something with her I have
not seen anything we typically don't get
a lot from the Senate we could see some
years with one maybe two maybe three um
it's we don't usually get overburdened
so in terms of our workload we've gone
through 90 of it without question so I
will look into it uh obviously you'll be
the first to know once we have crossover
and I get the bills
um but I don't have an exact answer for
you right now
any other questions
well all right thanks very much again if
you can give me the reports
wow
um
terrify
and secede okay
well if they engage in the crimes the
cops are not allowed to use violence if
necessary to address them yeah
yeah
um
it's kind of a touching they go at it
with the touchy feely you know they just
want to be free just let these people be
free they need better drugs you want to
foreign